you want me to go back to the States uh
yep
the day Debbie lands in Morocco Usama
drops a bombshell
and who has uprooted her life to live
there indefinitely that in one or two
months he wants her to leave
just like that ah yep I'm trying to keep
it together without wringing his neck
plus Gabe comes out as trans to his
friend Trey after a year of knowing each
other and Trey's reaction
it's something to see I'm trans so I was
like born a girl
whoa what the
let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissia I hope
you're doing well let's go ahead and get
into Debbie and Usama at the top of the
episode Miss Debbie just arrived in
Morocco and she is on cloud nine honey
and I feel like I'm home and that
everything's gonna be okay your feelings
are valid Debbie but that does not mean
they are true can I get an amen Osama
and I plan to stay a couple of days in
the capital city of rabac and then we're
gonna go meet Mom and Dad in chemistet
Debbie thinks that after she meets
usama's parents she and Usama will get
married and return to the capital city
and get an apartment which as we're
about to learn is not osama's plan but
before we get to that Debbie asks Usama
what his expectations are from her when
she becomes his wife first like I want
you like to be like half hour
my clothes
yeah something like this yeah
traditional Rose
it's just something about him telling
her that that makes it seem as if he's
just looking for another mom
but can we really be surprised
no
Usama didn't mention anything about
romance faithfulness affection spending
time together it was just about Debbie's
duties now I know men from different
cultures have different expectations but
at the age of 67 I don't think Debbie
came to Morocco to work I worked hard my
whole life I was waiting on Usama to
return the question to Debbie and asked
her what she expects from him as a
husband
that didn't happen why Osama at this
time are you saying I need to become
half of a Moroccan woman
you weren't telling me that stuff before
it's like Debbie was good and fine and
dandy for you but now it's like learning
how to cook and clean the Moroccan way I
need to be half a Moroccan woman this
was never a part of the plan
you know I don't know what I'm getting
myself into in chemistet
whoo
I need a drink just thinking about it
why is she so cute
we just have to make better decisions
when it comes to love Miss Debbie
[Music]
what is
fast forward Usama takes Debbie to this
romantic hotel Hi how are you
where the reservation is in her name
what
it was in her name
the fella said do you have reservations
[Music]
until we get married because it's a love
here Dutch Pine and dandy with Miss
Debbie I mean we're already like you
know overwhelmed with seeing each other
and our ideas and our plans I don't need
that Debbie said I don't need that
stress give me my space
when I spoke to her a few weeks ago I
asked if she and Usama get into it and
she kind of beat around the bush
no pun intended
out of line Osama has tried yeah no it's
like he's he's the red-blooded man it's
like he's tried but when I say no guess
what he respects me and then he's very
romantic you know most guys you know
it's all about grabbing and whatever and
it's like you know it's like yeah Osama
has his moments but he knows when no
means no and then he goes back to being
the gentleman
yeah yeah that sounds like a no and
let's be real Osama is 24. if he's not
sleeping with someone else now
eventually he will
[Music]
this is it tonight
this is my first day in Morocco wow what
a necklace are you with me lions
anyway once Debbie and Osama gets
settled at the hotel they decide to meet
in the courtyard so Debbie can get clear
on how long Osama plans to stay with his
mom and Dad aka is about to go down you
know I didn't give up my whole life in
the United States and my comfort zone
you know to live with Mom and Dad for an
indefinite period of time
y'all it looks so nice
do you like my princess yes
this is nice yeah
[Music]
how are you kind sir this evening wow
what happened
I didn't know since I have some energy
as you can see Debbie is pretty wrapped
up in this fairy tale idea
which makes you feel for her even more
after what comes next she asked Usama
how long she should prepare to stay at
his parents house a few days a week
this was his answer for me you can stay
all the time you want I'm gonna stay one
month in home two months all the time
she wants that sounds like the time you
want
uh you see how he tries to put it on her
that's sneaky
for me you can stay all the time you
want I'm gonna stay one month in home
two months also smoke point and even
asking why this conversation wasn't had
before she moved across the world
for some reason those conversations are
rare on 90 day
okay I need kind of a time frame because
okay once we go to Mom and Dad's and
then we need to like start looking at
apartments and robot too much I think
we need to save some money because it
will it will be expensive for us here
for now I mean we can stay in my pot of
home wait
what are you going to tell her how to
spend her money y'all need to save how
about you consider working how about
that
it's like he's trying to mask what he
really wants with words that sound as if
he's being considerate of her in this
moment you can tell Debbie is getting a
feeling that something is wrong she's
trying to keep that smile up but
disappointment
tapping at that heart you know the
feeling that initial stomach drop
us you will stay like 12 months or one
month after you will live to U.S
because I know that you will come back
for your business for your home you know
for something important
foreign
kind of confused at the point it's like
you say I'm gonna be here two months at
your mom and dad's house and then you
want me to go back to the States
uh yep
you want me to go back to the States uh
yep and then I when do I come back again
[Music]
well I think just
I mean come back when when
Debbie said we are not about to play
these games
speak come back when when
this is a decision of Life first you
have to know my family
tradition I never I'm in Spain like a
two months with you on the same house I
mean we have to know each other so
deeply
and after we will get married
wow I wish you would have told me that
before I I came right thankfully Debbie
didn't hold in what she really wanted to
say like some of us do and then we go
home and beat ourselves up for all the
things we should have said but no Debbie
speaks up and she lets Usama know this
is a disappointment and specifically I'm
disappointed in you
here's the deal Osama
I moved mountains to come over here
I hurt my kids
I had expectations and I believed your
word to me that you loved me and we were
to get married and now you're you're
telling me you're not going to marry me
and this is a two-month test drive
I thought we were gonna hear another yip
ah yep
I would have wanted to jump through the
screen for Debbie I need to live with
you on reality to see if you accept me
in reality if me accept you in reality
why couldn't you tell me gee Debbie why
don't you come and I'll see if I can
accept you in reality or not why didn't
you say something like that
because if I say to you this the
window's gone hmm let's call that what
it is
and that's manipulation now let me be
clear I'm actually for Usama and Debbie
not getting married
what I'm against is any person who sells
someone a dream and then when they get
you where they want you they tell you
it's time to live in reality it's it's
it's gaslighting that term is so
overused and misused at times but in
this case
it fits I know some of you might say
well what does Debbie expect she's
dealing with a 24 year old I personally
don't think this is an age thing there
are some extremely intelligent
considerate and wise 24 year olds this
is more of a character issue a lack of
Integrity on osama's part and with
everything that Debbie has to lose
it's dangerous
well how do you think I feel now what do
you think it's like to be sitting over
here looking like a fool Usama is
looking like he's about to go to sleep
he did say he was tired why didn't you
say Debbie don't pack all your stuff why
didn't you say Debbie slow down because
you know if things go good as we will
indeed
you really screwed up big time Osama
why it's like shame on you why
[Music]
shout out to Beyonce's thong resentment
oh
that used to be my gym you lied to me
I'm still want to marry you
you know what
I don't believe you anymore
that's the first time I mean there is
nothing changed in our love I don't
believe you
I'm using a tremendous amount of
self-control
I'm trying to keep it together without
wringing his neck Debbie shares that
when she was in Morocco last year Usama
was eager to get married and for some
reason all of that changed now it's a
concern Debbie opened up to me about too
and I started to feel bad I said well
maybe I gained 20 pounds maybe he thinks
I look fat then I said to myself maybe
he's got a young girlfriend and if he
does let me know because I let you go in
a heartbeat I want you to be happy you
know I'm not some lecherous old lady
looking to sink my claws into him he
said I want you to be happy and good in
life that's all I want if I'm not your
cup of tea hey I'm not going to force
you back to the episode Debbie tells
Usama that she's lost her confidence in
him
my expectations were you were gonna man
up
and now all of a sudden you've changed
your mind
a man's word is supposed to mean
something
say that again Debbie a man's word is
supposed to mean something
obviously I didn't know you as well as I
thought
I feel sick man oh Debbie and her
princess dress returned to her quarters
and who she thought was her prince is
looking more like a villain right now
seriously what's up with the lookusama
interesting recently I came across this
tweet that I love and after watching
Debbie nusama this week it made me think
of her it reads quote nothing is as
beautiful as seeing someone who has been
unlucky in relationships finally being
loved effortlessly by the right person
Debbie just wants her fairy tale ending
and after all that she's been through
including two failed marriages one that
resulted in her locking herself in the
house for 12 years I want that happy
ending for her too and to be frank
I don't think it's with Usama
bless his heart you know my pool for for
finding a nice man is very small
actually it's a little mud puddle it's
not even a pool what would be cool is if
the 90 day franchise created a wholesome
dating show for cast members like Debbie
bring on some therapists and
relationship experts and some nice older
single men who would truly be a good
match for her sometimes our life
experiences can cause our picker to be
off when looking for love and all we
need is some extra help and guidance I
think Debbie can use some of that extra
help
but all of this is wishful thinking for
the time being because Debbie has not
ended her relationship with Usama yet I
don't even know if that's gonna happen
we'll have to wait and see what the
season holds all right moving on I have
to show you this moment where we see
Gabe come out to his friend Trey as
trans they've been buddies for a year
and I have a little insight on how Gabe
handles these combos here's what he told
me last month I think an important times
in my life for events in my life then
yeah I tell people but on the daily on
the regular even
like in a year I really don't feel the
pressure to tell people if it's not
pertinent to what's happening right now
I don't feel like I needed help
so knowing that it was interesting to
watch him decide it's time to tell Trey
how you doing man hey man why some hoops
you ready yes Gabe and his friend Trey
who was also American but lives in
Colombia are playing basketball we hang
out all the time uh he's a cool guy and
Gabe tells Trey he wants to propose to
Isabel are you sure you want to get into
this
I'm already I feel like I'm already in
it I feel like I'm already invested like
I've already jumped in the deep end with
no floaties
I think that Gabe is jumping into this a
little bit too quick he's found somebody
that he truly thinks that he loves but
on the other hand do I know Gabe to the
impulsive absolutely dang Gabe's sister
said the same thing he has a tendency to
jump the gun and rush into things it can
get exhausting all right fast forward
Gabe starts to talk about how he is
going to go the traditional route and
ask Isabelle's dad for her hand in
marriage and that's when he drops the
news
I have to reveal something else to them
also what's that
I'm trans
so I was like horny girl
oh wait we have to take a look again at
how Trey looked Gabe up and down in pure
shock I'm trans
so I was like horny girl
whoa what the
Trey is reacting like he's getting
punked
whoa what the
okay to laugh
his reaction's hilarious to me and it's
cool how ultimately
he doesn't care
damn yep
so that's why I never added you on any
of my social media oh that's all good
man you're worried about me I know so
now I can add you for sure let's go yeah
I had no idea that Gabe is trans I mean
he plays football you know what I'm
saying he's a running back on the
football team out here so honestly you
know I never knew wow
well I mean look bro I'll support you or
whatever I know I'm like Trey I'm like
oh it'll come in time well after having
bad New pieces of information Trey
advises Gabe not to tell Isabelle's
parents and just ask to marry her
that's it no that's gonna be too much
yeah let's stick with the marriage thing
all right I don't know we've got a
couple of years down the line I just
want to rip the Band-Aid off
I mean bro this is a real patriarchal
culture I mean they don't play out here
you know real my cheese though I mean
it's one of those type of cultures bro
so like I don't know how her dad is
gonna handle this
I do have concerns for him you know to
move to another country being in a
culture that he's not really so familiar
with and to reveal that you are trans
it's a lot it's a lot to process yeah
Trey just put things into perspective
for sure at the end of the episode we
get a tease of what's still to come this
season and we get a sneak peek at the
moment Gabe decides to tell Isabelle's
parents his truth
I was born a win and I am trans
[Music]
you cannot wait to see that all right 90
day fans Fam thank you for spending some
time with me make sure you stick with ET
because we are covering it all I will
see you next time
foreign